KATHRIN O'SULLIVAN:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to this
Authors at Google talk.
My name is Kathrin O'Sullivan.
I work on the People
Development department.
And I have the great pleasure to
welcome Erica Dhawan here today
to talk to us about her work.
Erica is the CEO of Cotential
and works with companies
on getting big things
done through the power
of connectional intelligence.
That's also the title
of her book, which
you can purchase outside after
the session for a discounted
price of $10.
And Erica will also stay
and sign books for anybody
who would like that.
Erica is a leading thinker
and keynote speaker.
She's spoken globally at events
like the Global Economic Forum
in Davos.
She holds an MPA from
Harvard, an MBA from MIT,
and an MS in economics
from Wharton.
So I'm going to hand
it over to Erica
to talk to us about
her book and her work.
ERICA DHAWAN: Great.
Thank you so much.
It's great to be here
and to explore and talk
about connectional
intelligence here in this room.
And so in order to
do that, today I'm
here to really talk
about my new book,
"Get Big Things Done, the Power
of Connectional Intelligence"
that's co-authored with my
co-author Saj-Nicole Joni,
but more importantly to talk
to each and every one of you
about how connectional
intelligence can
be leveraged in your own
life, in your career here
at Google, and beyond.
So I'm going to dive
right in, and I'm
going to start with
telling you a little story.
And this is a story
about a leading law
firm based in New York.
The senior team at the law
firm noticed something peculiar
happening a few years ago.
They noticed that the
youngest associates
at the firm, the
millennial associates,
started to bill less
hours than ever before.
And this was quite peculiar,
because, one, they were giving
them more work, not less work.
And two is we all know law
firms bill by the hour.
So it was actually a concern.
And so when they
dug into it, they
discovered that actually these
millennial legal associates had
created their own
Twitter network
to help each other solve
cases faster, questions like,
I need this legal citation.
Does anyone know
where to find it?
Or, I know we did a case in
law school just like this.
What was the name of it?
And it became such a rapidly
productive community that it
was changing the bottom line.
But the story actually
doesn't stop there.
The legal firm has now taken
on an initiative called Twitter
at Work to help teach
everyone at the law firm
how to better use these tools.
But there's one flip
side to the story,
and that's the fact that
these young associates get
promoted through billing hours.
So the way that they're working
in a more productive way
is that actually, at the
heart, against the way
the industry is
still structured.
So today, we are going
to talk about a rising
change in the future of work.
And this is a
change that is being
embodied by the rise of the
multi-generational workplace.
We have four generations
in the workplace today.
And generations are simply
a manifestation of the way
that the world is changing.
So when we talk about
Traditionalists, Baby Boomers,
Gen X'ers and Gen Y'ers, also
known as the millennials,
we aren't just
talking about an age.
We're actually talking
of a cohort that
has a set of experiences,
a certain way
of working, mobilizing people,
solving problems, that's
actually a clue to the way work
will be changing in the future.
So let me first highlight this
also with where we're going.
Research shows that 75%
of the world's workforce
will be millennials by 2020.
And I'm here to talk to you
about what really brought me
into this research on
correctional intelligence,
and it stems from
this question of,
if we think about generations
as a manifestation of the way
that the world is
changing, just like it
did at the law firm, what's
unique about millennials?
And this is a big
hot topic right now
that many people are asking.
And what I'm
actually here to say
is that often what
you hear about what's
unique about millennials
isn't actually true.
And when you ask, what you
hear from what millennials
might say they
want might actually
be contradicted in action.
So let me explain.
Research shows that
72% of millennials
want to have ownership
or to be their own boss.
But when we actually look at
where the next generation goes
when they leave a
large organization,
they actually more often don't
just start their own company.
They go and join another
small or large organization.
So having entire
ownership or being
your entirely own boss
isn't unique to millennials.
The second thing
that we've heard
is that 88% of
millennials desire
a viable work-life integration.
And while work-life is
incredibly important,
if you actually look at
the Fortune 500 companies
and you look at the best
work-life flexibility programs,
you actually see that there
is not a significant decrease
in turnover among young talent.
So while work-life integration
it is a great perk,
it actually is something
that we all want,
and it's not unique to
millennials in terms
of why they stay at a company.
The third thing we hear is
that 88 of the next generation
desire a collaborative
work culture.
And collaborative work
cultures are fantastic, just
like one here Google.
But again, when we look at
the research, what we find
is that there isn't a
significant decrease
in turnover looking at
the best companies that
have the highest rated
collaborative work cultures.
So again, ladies and
gentlemen, that's not unique to
millennials.
And fourth, we hear
that 74% of millennials
desire a lot of flexibility.
But again, if we look at the
top companies around the world,
flexibility programs have
remained a perk but not a game
changer when we really
talk about fully engaging
our best talent and retaining
them in the workplace today.
So, ladies and gentlemen, what
is unique about millennials?
I want to start by quoting a
famous quote by Henry Ford.
Henry Ford said, if I had
asked people what they wanted,
they would have
said, faster horses.
And I'm actually here to
kick this off and say,
if we look at the
future of work,
oftentimes what we hear isn't
exactly what people mean.
And when actually
making a decision,
it could look actually
quite different.
But I do want to say that
there is one thing that
is unique to the future work
mindset that's manifested
by millennials but is really
used by all generations
in the workforce today.
And what I want to say
is that it's not only
a core competency of
the future of work,
but it's a core
competency in reaching
your customers, clients,
and other stakeholders more
intelligently in the
next wave of the century.
And that is what my
coauthor Saj-Nicole Joni
and I call connectional
intelligence.
Connectional intelligence
is the ability
to combine knowledge,
ambition, and human capital,
forging connections
on a global scale that
create unprecedented
value and meaning.
So what does this
look like in action?
I'm going to start
by telling you
a story of some unimaginable
transformations and examples
of connectional intelligence.
The first is about a
grandmother, right up there.
And this grandmother is part of
a unique cadre of grandmothers
called The Granny Cloud.
Has anyone heard of
the Granny Cloud?
Raise your hand if you have.
No?
So the Granny Cloud is a cadre
of grandmothers in the UK
and Australia who
use video Skype
to Skype weekly with Indian
children throughout India.
And it all started
through an experiment
that a professor named
Sugata Mitra ran.
This was an experiment where
he embedded computer kiosks
with Wi-Fi into slum
areas throughout India.
And what he wanted to see is,
if you just left the computer
there, what would happen?
How would the children use it?
And what he saw is
that when he came back
a month or two months later,
the young children had entirely
learned how to use a
computer themselves.
And they were getting online.
There was Wi-Fi enabled.
And the first thing
that they tried to do
was to learn English and
practice their English.
So while this started to
get momentum and these
hole-in-the-wall kiosks started
to spread and also to get known
around the world, there was a
group of grandmothers in the UK
that said, hey, we
want to help, too.
And when you think of help
from the original context,
you'd ask these
grandmothers for money.
But they said, we
want to do more.
And so they created the
Granny Cloud in partnership
with Sugata Mitra's team.
And today, there are
hundreds of grandmothers
around the world that
are using the Granny
Cloud not only to connect with
each other through a Facebook
group and an email
newsletter, but to connect
through video Skype
with these children.
And you think that
the story stops there
and the grandmothers
are the givers.
But actually, it doesn't.
In fact, research
is now being done
to show that video interaction
with grandmothers and those
at elderly age
actually increases
their cognitive ability
as they decline.
So the Granny Cloud,
again, is not only
creating a one-way form of
connectional intelligence,
but it's truly creating
a two-way connectivity
engagement that is
transforming people's lives
around the world.
The second story I want
to share is a story
about Patrick Meier who
ran an initiative called
Ushahidi-Haiti.
Patrick spent two years
in Haiti before going back
to Tufts University grad school,
the Fletcher School there.
And back a few years ago when
the Haiti earthquake hit,
he was at Tufts in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
But he was extremely
overwhelmed,
and he was instantly
trying to reach out
to his friends in
Haiti that were there
during the earthquake.
So the first thing
that he started to do,
sitting from his
computer lab at Tufts,
was to start to
track the tweets.
Because half of Haiti had
power, and half of Haiti didn't.
So he tried to track
any tweets that
were coming in from Haiti from
his friends and other people.
And then he had been a part
of a team that had embedded
something called Ushahidi.
And Ushahidi is basically
Google Maps meets Twitter,
where basically you can track
tweets and text messages
and map them to the location
where they're coming from.
So he started to do this by
himself, tracking tweets.
And then he got a team around
him at Tufts University
to ask others to
engage with him as well
to track this information.
Soon enough, they had built
a map of hundreds of reports.
They not only did that,
they reached out to someone
through Twitter that was in
Cameroon that knew the largest
telecommunications
company in Haiti
to get a 911-type symbol up
so people could also share
through text message alerts.
And these are
people sharing where
they were, where survivors
were that needed to be moved
to safer ground and beyond.
So the next thing
that happened is
that many of these texts and
tweets were in Haitian Creole.
So what Patrick did sitting
in Cambridge, Massachusetts,
is he invited the
Haitian diaspora,
the immigrant community, to come
in and translate these tweets
and created almost a
makeshift, 24/7 operating room
to track these messages.
Within just a few
days in that week,
the Marine Corps and
the US Coast Guard
started to use
Patrick's Ushahidi map
to both find survivors and
move them to safer ground
and to even find
survivors that were
under rubble that
would have never been
saved without Patrick's map.
And so by connecting a
disparate group of people,
by using connectivity
and people around him
in Cambridge,
Massachusetts, he not only
was able to connect with
his friends in Haiti,
but he was actually able to
save lives in partnership
with government.
The third story I
want to share is
the story of the Oreo
tweet at Super Bowl 2013.
Has anyone seen this ad before?
Tell us where it's
from, the person that
just raised their hand.
Yes, Super Bowl 2013.
So raise your hand if
you remember the blackout
during the Super Bowl?
Yes you can tell who
watches the Super Bowl.
In Super Bowl 2013,
there was a blackout,
and it didn't just
last a few minutes.
It lasted 45 minutes.
Many people blame
Beyonce for that.
She was performing right before.
But anyway, the
blackout happened,
and while the
players were trying
to keep their muscles warm and
most other people were eating
snack chips, Oreo at
that time came out,
in just four minutes
of the blackout,
with an ad that said, power out?
No problem.
You can dunk an Oreo in the
dark, this ad, half lit,
half dark ad.
They posted it on Twitter.
It went absolutely viral,
over 15,000 retweets,
20,000 Facebook Likes.
And the next day, it was dubbed
the best ad of the Super Bowl,
beating out every
multimillion-dollar commercial,
made in four minutes, and
basically didn't cost anything.
So how did this happen?
Well, the Oreo team knew
that breakthroughs don't just
happen.
You have to prepare for them.
You have to be connectionally
intelligent about upbringing
the right people together.
So what the had
previously done is
they made sure at
every big event or game
they actually practiced by
getting every big decision
maker in the room together.
So they got the legal team, the
executives, the social media,
the design agency to come
together for every big event
just to see if they might be
able to capitalize on an idea.
And so it was at
that time when they
saw this happen, because they
had naturally been doing this,
prepare to act fast and be
relevant, that they actually
broke through with this ad.
And today, brands everywhere
are trying to reinvent and learn
from this, because
it truly is flipping
the mindset of how
marketers will market
at big events in the future.
And the fourth story
I want to tell you
is the story of the
Doritos guacamole chip.
They're delicious, by the way.
But I actually want
to ask you first,
when you think of a Doritos
guacamole chip, what department
at Frito Lay would
come up with this chip,
would create this chip?
Tell me.
R&D, yep, R&D,
product innovation.
So you would think it would
come from R&D and product
innovation, but in
fact, it didn't.
This Doritos guacamole
chip came and was
discovered by the Latino
Employee Resource Network
at Frito Lay.
So the Latino Network
typically comes together
for employee engagement.
And when they came
together, they
said, well, we don't want to
just connect with each other.
We actually want to solve
a real business challenge.
And one of the
things they asked is,
why don't we have a Doritos
chip for the Latino customer
segment?
So they did research.
They pitched this idea
to product innovation.
Product innovation
had never taken ideas
from a diversity network.
They ended up trying it.
It was $100 million product.
Then the Asian network says,
hey, we want to do this, too.
They came up with
a curry chip that's
a best seller throughout Asia.
And today, the
company systematically
brings together every
single diversity network
to come up with product ideas
for their target segment.
So what began as one informal
network that wasn't set up
to come up with product
ideas, when combined,
was able to help the
business and also then
got turned into a more
systematic, sustained effort
throughout the company.
So these are all
some examples of
some unimaginable
transformations
in today's world.
And today's goals
are really, first,
to help you understand what
is connectional intelligence.
And I just gave you
a set of examples
that help to highlight some
of the research that we did
and some of the stories
that we feature in the book.
But now I want to
talk a little bit more
about how can you identify how
connectional intelligence is
used and learn how to apply
it to your work, to your life,
to your career here at Google.
So in order to do
that, I want you
to understand what's in it for
you and for your organization.
Connectional intelligence
is a leadership skill.
But it has huge applications
for business results,
whether it's growing
talent, whether it's
driving growth,
managing risks, enabling
those interdisciplinary
breakthroughs.
And the most important thing
about connectional intelligence
is it's a human skill that
can be used by anyone, that
can be used by an intern
at Google, by the CEO,
by someone starting
out, by someone
in a siloed function that
might see a new way of solving
a problem in a unique
way that might actually
help many more than you
might have ever thought.
So in order to
describe that, there
are five fundamental
capabilities
of connectional intelligence--
curiosity, combination,
courage, community,
and combustion.
And let me go through each to
give you a better feel of this.
So the first is curiosity.
And curiosity from a
connectional intelligence
perspective is the ability
to broaden your perspective,
to ask a different
set of questions
before you solve a problem.
So in the case of
Oreo, they truly
have the curiosity
to ask, how might we
get everyone ready to act
when it really matters?
That ad could have
taken six months
to create and
hundreds of thousands,
if not millions, of dollars.
But instead, they focused
on being prepared.
To asked the question, how can
we be prepared and relevant
when it matters most?
And another example of
curiosity is a story
that we feature in the book
about a man named Ron Wallace.
That man is Ron Wallace.
And ladies and gentlemen, that
is his 2,000-pound pumpkin.
There is something called
be Topsfield Fair, which
hosts the world's
largest pumpkin contest.
And every year,
pumpkin farmers compete
to grow the world's
largest pumpkin.
And to give you a sense,
from the beginning of time
to the year 2000, the
largest pumpkin ever grown
was 1,000 pounds.
And in a mere 12 years, in 2012,
Ron Wallace grew a 2,000-pound
pumpkin, doubling
the world's record.
So how did this happen?
Well, Ron Wallace
knew that he had
to connect with
other fields in order
to truly understand how to grow
the world's largest pumpkin.
So what he did is over
a series of years,
he first contacted many
scientists around the world,
asking them about new soil
science, new ways of working.
He also connected with
potato farmers when
he read about how there was
one specific fungi that potato
farmers used to radically
expand the size of potatoes,
that he then tried
with pumpkins,
and it radically grew
the size of pumpkins.
He not only did that, he created
a small circle of association
in Rhode Island where pumpkin
farmers in Rhode Island
would come together to
share best practices,
even though they
were all competing
with each other for
the big contest.
And he became a leading
contributor to bigpumpkins.com.
It's a site where pumpkin
farmers around the world
share best practices.
So in 2012, through his
connectional intelligence,
Ron Wallace, in his true
curiosity to ask different
questions, Ron Wallace wins
the world's largest pumpkin
contest, growing a
2,000-pound pumpkin.
But the story actually
doesn't stop there.
In fact today, small-scale
farmers in places like India
and throughout
sub-Saharan Africa
are now use using Ron's
discovery of the fungi
that he found with the potato
farmers to grow big crops,
because they can't afford
chemical fertilizer.
So in fact today, Ron Wallace is
not only growing big pumpkins.
He's shaping the global food
supply in big agriculture.
So for you, the
question is really,
how can you use different
tools and forums
to broaden your perspective
before you solve problems?
Where do you go to
find information?
And are there new
forms or new sets
of places to find and
collect that information?
The second C I want to
talk about is Courage.
And courage, from the
connectional intelligence
perspective, is
really this ability
to have difficult and diverse
conversations despite forces
to silence and control.
One of the great
examples of this
is the Nike Green
Exchange program.
Has anyone heard of the
Nike Green Exchange program?
Nike a few years ago decided
to release 400 of their patents
for noncompetitive,
environmentally sustainable use
by other companies.
And this initiative was
called Green Exchange.
And they did this
because they understood
that in order to create
change in this industry,
in order to be a leading
player in sustainability,
they would have to act first and
do something really courageous.
Soon enough, what
they began to see
is that their patents
were able to be
used in many different ways.
For example, one patent in
Nike shoes, one robber patent,
ended up being used
by a mountain biking
company in their tires.
And soon enough,
many other companies
began to follow,
including Creative Commons
and Best Buy and beyond.
And they were truly able to
create a new conversation
about how to better leverage
and share intellectual property
for non-competitive
and sustainable use.
And the second
example of courage
from a connectional
intelligence perspective
is the story of how Lance
Armstrong got caught doping.
Does anyone know the story?
How did Lance
Armstrong get caught
doping in the biking scandal?
So, many people think
that Lance Armstrong
got ratted out by his
colleagues, other cyclists.
But in fact, that
did happen, but that
didn't break the story
in the news altogether.
There was buzz,
but at that time,
Lance Armstrong was a hero.
Everyone wanted to be buddies
with him, because at that time,
it was the Livestrong campaign.
So what actually
happened is while there
was some small buzz without
any major media agency
really pushing this out,
a group of scientists
looked at Lance Armstrong's
cycling history.
And when they looked
at one specific race,
they saw roughly no
indication of doping.
But when they looked
over a 10-year history,
they saw a very clear
indication of doping.
And they didn't have a
big media agency that
wanted to cover this,
so they posted it
on a small biking blogging
in New Work called New York
Velocity.
And this biking blog was
filled with bicyclists
who just love to tell the
truth and share in the movement
around cycling.
So they posted it
there, and then
a group of basically
cyclist activists
on Twitter and Facebook
started to spread the story.
And it was after a few
months that through spreading
this story, that it actually
broke through in national media
and led to Lance
Armstrong's real opening
in that Oprah interview.
So what truly
happened is that it
was a combination of
bloggers, of scientists,
and cyclists who
had no incentive
but to tell the
truth that actually
led to the breakthrough in
discovering the lie that many
of us didn't know.
So the question for
you do is really,
how are you sparking
courageous conversations
in your target networks?
Where are the courageous
conversations happening?
And how can you engage with
them in an entirely new way that
might solve the pressing
challenges that you're
facing, just like
Lance Armstrong
or just like Nike
Green Exchange?
The third C of
connectional intelligence
is what's called Combination.
And combination by definition
is the root of innovation,
combining many disparate
ideas to come up
with an entirely new concept,
product, or innovation.
And some of the best
examples of this, of course,
is the story of the Doritos
guacamole chip bringing
together the Latinos at
the company to come up
with a new product idea.
But it also happens
in many other forms.
One example of that is Duolingo.
Who here knows what Duolingo is?
Tell us what Duolingo is.
AUDIENCE: It's a [INAUDIBLE].
ERICA DHAWAN: Yes,
it's basically
a language learning app.
It's entirely free.
It's almost like a free
version of Rosetta Stone.
But many of you might
not know that while it's
a free language
learning app, it also
serves as a crowdsourced
text translation platform.
So let me explain.
The founder, Luis
von Ahn of Duolingo,
understood and
asked the question,
how can I combine
solving one problem
and solve an entirely different
problem at the same time?
So one of the
problems he saw was
that people around the world
needed to learn new languages.
And he said, how could I
teach the world new languages
for free?
The second problem
that he saw is
that many online websites,
whether it was something
like BuzzFeed or CNN, needed
to effectively translate
their sites from English to
French or Japanese to Mandarin
in a very quick way.
And so what he actually did
is he combined the two needs.
And using Duolingo, when
players play Duolingo,
becuase it runs
basically as a game,
they're not just doing
random homework problems
of translating
English to French.
They're actually
translating news websites.
So when a certain
aggregate amount of people
translate the game at the
same time in the correct way,
it automatically translates
news websites around the world.
So when you think about this,
how might you be combining?
Just like the Doritos
guacamole chip and Duolingo,
how are you combining
information and knowledge
from inside and
outside your workplace?
Where might you be able
to solve one problem
and solve an entirely different
problem at the same time
by combining needs in a new way?
The fourth C of interconnection
all intelligence is Community.
And community is
the root of the idea
of bringing people together
to care, to spark, to inspire
together.
And one of my favorite
stories from our book
is a story at Colgate.
A few years ago, Colgate
had a big science problem.
They had developed
a new fluoride,
and they were trying
to get their fluoride
into their new toothpaste.
But there was something
wrong, and the fluoride
was getting stuck in the
mechanical equipment,
and it wasn't meshing well.
And all the best
chemists of the company
were trying to figure this out.
And they had difficulty.
And it was costing
them a lot of money,
because they couldn't get the
new product out to market.
So what they decided
to do is they
decided to post this
question in an anonymous way
on a website called InnoCentive.
Anyone here know
what InnoCentive is?
InnoCentive is a website
of inventors, hackers,
problem solvers,
people that just
want to solve unique problems.
So what they did is they
posted it on the site,
and within just a few
days, a physicist named
Ed Melcarek looked
at the site and said,
this isn't a chemistry problem.
This is a physics problem.
It's about chargeback particles.
You charge the fluoride one way.
You charge the
toothpaste the other.
Instantly, the
problem was solved,
saving the company a lot of
money, but not only doing that,
really allowing them to
see how they could leverage
a new type of network to solve
a problem that they couldn't
solve internally.
And when we interviewed
Ed Melcarek for the book,
one of the things he
said is that he may never
have been hired by
Colgate, because he didn't
have the traditional resume.
So what we can actually do is
we can engage new communities
in ways that we never would
have imagined that can actually
help us solve the problems
we're facing in real time.
The second story I'd
like to share is Uber.
Who here knows what Uber is?
Everyone's hands raised, right?
So when you end an
Uber ride, what's
the last thing you do
before you leave the car?
What's the last thing you
have to do to close the ride
and get your receipt?
Tell me.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERICA DHAWAN: Yes,
you rate your driver.
And what does your driver do?
AUDIENCE: Rate.
ERICA DHAWAN: Yes, the
driver is rating you
while you're rating your driver.
And the reason why
this is important
is because if you are not
a great customer on Uber,
you could, at a certain
point, get kicked off.
Because for the first
time, really, there's
optimal nodes flowing
to optimal resources
in a two-way community
where we're really
rating each other
in a way to improve
our behaviors over time.
And so as we think
about the communities
of the future in a
connectionally intelligent
mindset, it's really about how
might you create the incentive
structure to allow
people to care,
to spark, and inspire
together, but also
allow for a systematic
way, just like Uber is,
to bring the right
set of customers
with the right drivers together?
So I really want
you to think about,
when you're solving
a problem today,
one way to do it would be
through the Colgate example.
How might you be
leveraging communities
outside your existing network?
And another way would be, how
are you creating the incentive
structures for communities
to act in the most
efficient, productive way?
The fifth C is Combustion.
And combustion from a
connectionally intelligent
perspective is this ability
to mobilize resources
in pursuit of a large goal.
One of the examples
of combustion
is a story about SAP.
A series of years ago, SAP had a
big customer call waiting list.
They were overwhelmed with
customer service costs.
And so one of the
experiments they did
is they created an open,
peer-to-peer customer platform
where any customer
could actually
ask any other customer a
question about the product
or service.
And over 100,000 people
used it back in the day.
Today, over two million
people have used the site.
The average response
time is 16 minutes.
99% of queries are answered
correctly within 24 hours.
But the other thing that really
led to this platform combusting
is it's one of the top ways for
SAP to identify the products
and services that they should
be marketing and delivering
in the future.
Because they truly
understand and have
the intelligence of what
customers are really asking for
and what they need.
The second example of
combustion is the story
of My Starbucks platform.
Has anyone seen this
platform or know what it is?
So who knows what the
Starbucks green stick
is that you put in your coffee?
Does anyone know what that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KATHRIN O'SULLIVAN: Yes.
So Starbucks has a green stick.
It's called a swizzle stopper.
And it's used to make sure
that your coffee doesn't spill.
And for many people, it's
an iconic brand component
for Starbucks because
it's so well known.
And many people
don't know, though,
that it actually came as
an idea from a customer
through something called the
My Starbucks platform, which
is a crowdsourcing platform
where customers can share
their ideas for the
store, for products
that they should be delivering,
for different services they
should be offering.
And today, Starbucks
implements hundreds
of these ideas every year.
They get thousands of ideas.
And it's a top way, as
well, to truly combust,
just like the case with
the green stick, which
is an iconic model for
the Starbucks brand today.
So for you, the
question is really,
how are you going to mobilize
your networks to collaborate
to achieve a goal?
When you may start an
initiative for one way,
just like Ron Wallace was trying
to grow the world's largest
pumpkin or the legal
associates were just
trying to work
faster, how might it
combust in an entirely
different way that could really
help others and
outside networks,
whether it's inside Google,
outside with clients
and customers to solve your
most pressing challenges?
And so what I share
now is that when
we think about connectional
intelligence, it's not new.
The great leaders of
our time in history
have had very high
connectional intelligence,
whether it was Marie Curie or
Ben Franklin or Mahatma Gandhi.
But today, and as we know
here as leaders at Google,
the scale, depth, and
breadth of our connection
is radically different.
And it's changing
the way that we
solve problems, not only the way
that we might use technology,
but how we think and act,
mobilize resources, have
the courage to connect with
people around the world,
have the curiosity to
ask different questions
and then combine those
ideas in new ways.
And when you think about
connectional intelligence, what
you'll understand in the
book is that it's best
to think about it
at different levels.
So the first level
is the power of one,
is you as an individual.
How can you use your own
connectional intelligence
get big things done, just
like Ron Wallace did,
a pumpkin farmer, and
for each and every one
of you, whether it's working
your way up or solving
or launching a big product?
And so as you think about that,
what you'll find in the book
is a connectional intelligence
quiz, where you can actually
assess how and where you're
using connectional intelligence
in your work and in your life.
The second type are
the power of tens,
so the power of small teams.
This is the Oreo team that
said, we need to come together,
and it's when we're
acting together
in this relevant and fast
way that we're really going
to get something big done.
And the third type is
the power of thousands.
And the power of thousands
here is really this idea
that Colgate harnessed when
they launched and sent out
a question to a large
network of solvers.
And from those
thousands, they were
able to scan and source it
and find the physicist that
was able to help
them truly break
through a difficult challenge.
So as you think
about the future--
and I started the talk
talking about the next wave
in the future.
And I also was talking about
redefining the next generation
of millennials, not just as an
age, but as a mindset shift,
that we are in an age where
actually some of our greatest
connectional intelligence might
even come from our youngest.
And so in order to forge
a new way of thinking
across generations, we
need senior leaders,
and we need younger
leaders to come together
to act together in
new ways of problem
solving just like we saw
when the productivity
idea from the legal
associates is now changing
the way the firm is
thinking about productivity
in the future.
And so when you use
connectional intelligence,
you'll find that it will
benefit your customers,
your constituents, but also the
planet and larger societies.
And it can be used by
anyone in your workplace,
whether it's an individual,
a small team, or a larger
crowd or network.
And what you'll find when you
harness connection intelligence
and you read more
stories in the book,
you'll find that it will help
you move from this idea of just
serendipity.
And we all love serendipity.
It's the way some of the
magic happens at places
here like at Google.
But it will help you
create more intention,
a more strategic
way of accelerating
more of those
serendipitous reactions.
And as we saw with the story
of the Oreo Super Bowl tweet,
luck comes to the prepared.
So how can you create
a more systematic way
of leveraging the connections
and networks around you,
whether it's people,
ideas, or resources?
So in the book,
what you'll find is
that we talk about three types
of connectional intelligence.
And the way I'll help you frame
this that 10 years ago, Malcom
Gladwell coined the concept of
a connector as one of the three
ways that create
the rise of social
epidemics-- the mavens,
the salespeople,
and the connectors.
And while that idea was quite
revolutionary at the time,
today it's quite outdated.
Because as we all know,
today we are all connectors.
In fact, we are over-connected.
So how do we get big things
done through our connections?
And what we found
in our research is
that in today's world, it's not
about being a connector or not,
it's what type of
connector you are.
And there are three
types of connectors,
and you'll take a quiz
in the book to figure out
which one you are.
They are the thinkers, the
enablers, and the connection
executioners.
The thinkers are those that
have the highest in curiosity,
as I shared before.
They are the ones that
are like Ron Wallace
the pumpkin farmer that asked
a different set of questions
to help broaden your perspective
before you solve a problem.
The second type of
connector are the enablers.
The enablers are
those that understand
how to forge ties and bring
the right resources together
in pursuit of a goal.
So these might be the highest
when it comes to community,
so the Colgate example
where they were able to see,
we should enable another
group of inventors and problem
solvers to help us solve
this science challenge.
And the third type of connector
are the connection executors.
These are the people
that understand
how to mobilize your resources
to get it done in action.
They may be launching
the next Google product.
They might be the
legal associates
that I described using the
Twitter at work network.
And so the question today, and
you'll find this in the book,
is to understand what
type of connector are you,
and what's the big thing
you're trying to get done?
And if you're
naturally a thinker,
but you need to actually have
a team of connection executors
around you, you can better
understand, who do you
need to bring on your team?
Who do you need to
forge ties with?
If you're naturally
a connection executor
but you like to be
in your zone, but you
need to work across
different silos,
who are the enablers
that you know
across Google or in
your customer client
base that you could
actually bring in
to help you solve that problem?
So as you go through
and understand what type
of connector you are, you'll
get to better understand
where you fit in
across the five season
Cs of connectional
intelligence that I described.
Thinkers are highest
in curiosity.
Enablers are highest
in community.
And connection executors
are the combustion leaders.
They know how to
mobilize a resource
to get something big done.
So if you're thinking
about how can you
bring correctional
intelligence here,
the first thing is to broaden
the knowledge base around what
connectional intelligence is and
how you can each use it, again,
as a human skill
to solve problems.
There's no doubt that
this is the leading
place for technology.
But what's important
is how we as people
are leveraging all of
our resources and ways
to get the big things done.
The second is obviously around
technology and thinking about,
how might you not only leverage
technology, but create ways
where people are systematically
and scalably connecting?
And the third is to talk to
your senior teams about this.
How are they using
connectional intelligence?
How can this be a
way to forge ties
across generations here
at places like Google
and with your clients
and customers?
So in order to do
finish this up,
I want you to close
with three things
that I want you to do to take
home in an actionable way.
And there's lots of other
tools and tips in the book.
The first is a 10-minute rule.
And it's a 10-minute rule to
spend 10 minutes every day
connecting with a new source
of news or perspective
outside your own.
So if you're the person that
gets your news on Twitter
or on Facebook, maybe it's
reading three new influencer
blogs in your industry.
Or if you're someone that has a
hobby in an entirely different
thing, maybe it's
spending 10 minutes
actually investing
in that hobby that
could turn into something
really interesting for business.
The second is to spend
time with two people that
think very differently than
you at least once a month.
So if you're a
thinker, I'm going
to ask you to find the enabler
and the executor that you know
and spend time with them and
ask them how they would solve
problems that you're facing.
And the third thing
is, in the book,
you'll find a
manager guide where
you can run a
connectional intelligence
workshop with your
team to figure out who
and what are the different
connectors in your group.
How many thinkers do you have?
How many enablers?
How many executors?
And when you do
that, you can help
to redesign and think about
what might be missing.
And it's really amazing,
because depending on your group,
you cannot often guess what
people are naturally good at.
But what you'll hear
is that oftentimes, you
have to adjust based on
the role that you're in.
So if you're in a role
that requires an enabler,
you might be an
enabler in that role.
But over lunch, you might
be more of a thinker.
So it's good to understand
what type of roles
do you have to play to
get something big done,
and what roles are
you naturally are,
and run that little
session with your team.
So in closing, I want
to thank you again
for coming and
discussing this-- I think
we might have some
time for Q&A--
and diving into what
connectional intelligence is
all about.
The other quick
things that I'm giving
is a freebie giveaway,
is if you text the number
66866 with the word
"Erica" just on your phone,
you'll receive
the details to get
a free connectional intelligence
quiz and manager guide.
And the last thing is
if you're interested,
host a connectional intelligence
training with your team.
So there's many
different ways to do it.
I'm happy to talk to you more
about what that looks like.
But most importantly,
what this will do
is it will help you move from
those serendipitous encounters
to leveraging and
intentionally leveraging
all of the connections around
you to get big things done.
So the last thing
I want to leave you
with before we close
and dive into questions
is that connectional
intelligence
is an amazing force.
And it can be used in
lots of different ways.
It can be used to launch a
multimillion dollar product,
but it can also be used to
help a community that may not
be business people
or rich or successful
to actually get
something big done.
And in the book, we don't
just profile businesses,
but we profile individuals,
neighborhood communities,
college students, young kids,
those in different industries
across the world, whether it's
agriculture or sports that
are getting big things done.
So I encourage you to
ask the question of,
how will you use
connectional intelligence
as a force for good,
for all of those
that are counting on your
wisdom, your creativity,
and your heart?
Thank you so much, and
we'll dive into questions.
AUDIENCE: So different--
like a sociologist
would say that having a group
of people together collaborating
can actually be really
dangerous at times.
Because if they all
think the same way
and reinforce each other, and
there's an error in the logic,
then basically it's
just groupthink, right?
How in connectional intelligence
can you avoid that problem?
ERICA DHAWAN: Great question.
So connectional
intelligence is very
different from collaboration.
So collaboration is
about sharing ideas
with a lot of people.
But you can do
that, as you said,
and share with a lot of
people, and get nothing done.
You can also cause groupthink
or kill creativity.
So connectional intelligence
is about understanding,
how can you more intentionally
bring together the right people
at the times when it
really matters most?
And that is done
by understanding,
what are the different types of
connectors that are around you
on your team?
Because if you put together
just a group of thinkers,
you might get nothing
done, because they all
might love to collaborate
and share ideas,
but they're not going through
the flow of really executing.
If you put together
a group of executors,
you might get the same rote
routine every single time.
So that's why it's so
important to understand
what type of connectors are
in these different groups.
And understand that this
isn't about more collaboration
with everyone.
This is about using the five
C's of connectional intelligence
to understand, when do we need
to broaden our perspective
and solve a problem?
And what are the right sets of
communities actually to come
together to solve this problem?
Great question.
AUDIENCE: For the Colgate
example that you demonstrated,
when you crowdsource an
answer with the public
and then he comes up with a
multimillion dollar answer,
now is Colgate responsible
to pay this person?
Because actually
in written form,
there's a whole message
log of how the idea came
to through to fruition.
Can you explain a
little more about that?
ERICA DHAWAN: Yeah, absolutely.
So the way that
InnoCentive works is there
is a cash prize for the winner.
So Ed Melcarek, the physicist,
did receive a cash prize.
But it's set up in a way so
it's completely anonymous,
the name of the company.
So companies are able
to ask these questions
without revealing
confidential information.
Secondly, there is a cash prize
for the winner who answers it
correctly, which
enables and creates
an incentive for
the problem solvers.
But when I talked to Ed and also
others that use InnoCentive,
for them it's also the journey
of expanding their curiosity,
of solving problems,
and learning from others
to see what they share.
So I think from both
the confidentiality
and the incentive structure,
they've gotten it right.
The other thing I'll share
is that crowdsourcing is also
different from
connectional intelligence.
Because you can source a lot of
ideas, but really in that case,
the incentive and design
of solving that problem
and bringing the
right groups together
is what allowed the
connectional intelligence
and that breakthrough
to happen for Colgate.
AUDIENCE: So you give
a lot of examples
of when connectional
intelligence work really
well in your talk.
Can you give an example
of when it didn't work,
when someone tried to do
this but it didn't work?
ERICA DHAWAN: Yeah, absolutely.
And it's a great question.
And the other thing I'll
say is I can give you
examples of where connectional
intelligence didn't work,
but also how it can
turn into a disaster.
It could be used for
great evil, right?
And so there's no
denying that we
can use connectional
intelligence as
a force for good or as
not a force for good.
And that's why I ended
with that piece of,
how will you use it
as a force for good?
I think a couple
of examples of this
might have been a
few years ago, Gap
tried to crowdsource
a new brand logo.
And they crowdsourced an idea.
They changed their brand logo.
They launched it in the market.
So they tried to
engage a large crowd.
They tried to be connected.
And after they did that,
most of their market
hated the new
brand, and there was
a huge rejection of the brand.
And it actually led them to
change the brand again and go
back to what they had before.
Another example of
this was-- and this
is sort of a flip to the Oreo
tweet, was during the World Cup
based on what KLM
Airlines had tweeted.
Did anyone see this?
So during the World
Cup last year in 2014,
KLM Airlines tweeted
something and made a joke
about the
Netherlands-Mexico game.
And the team in Mexico was not
happy about what they shared.
And some of the leading figures
in Mexico responded on Twitter
and said, we will
never fly KLM again.
And it actually created this
overflow of bad PR press
for KLM, when what
they were trying to do
was respond and make a
joke about the World Cup.
So actually, as we think about
connectional intelligence,
there's no denying that when
we try things, we may fail.
Or it may go in a way
that we never expected.
And that's by nature
something that
happens when we always
open ourselves up
to new people and ideas.
That's why courage
is so important.
But what's critical is
that in the case of Gap
or in the case of KLM, we
can't just let it happen.
We have to keep
engaging the community.
Because the brands
and the leaders
are actually ones
that won't stop at,
OK, this went downhill,
unless you go bankrupt, right?
But what they'll do, and
this is what KLM has done,
is they've tried to
reengage their population.
And they understand that there
will be issues like this,
but you almost have to
do some of that practice
in order to engage
your customer base
to make them feel that
you're actually human,
that you're authentic,
and you're actually
building a long-term
relationship with them.
KATHRIN O'SULLIVAN: Thank
you so much for coming.
Thank you, Erica.
It was grea to have you here.
ERICA DHAWAN: Think you.
Let me know if you have
any other questions.
[APPLAUSE]